STARTED SINCE WE HAVE THE AS
WELL.
OKAY WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL CONVENE. OUR.
REGULARLY SCHEDULED BMP.
COMMITTEE MEETING.
.
WE'LL START OFF WITH ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
YEAH.
OKAY.
THE.
CHAIR NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM AT THIS POINT IN TIME AND
SO I WILL BEGIN.
WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE SINCE WE
HAVE OUR COMMITTEE MEMBER AND
AUTHOR. PRESENCE AND SO
BEGINNING WITH THE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB IS SEVEN FORTY NINE SEVEN
WHATEVER YOU LIKE.
LOW AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS EIGHTY
SEVEN FOUR NINE PROVIDES A MUCH
NEEDED UPDATE TO THE REAL ESTATE
LAW WHICH HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED
IN DECADES.
THE BILL AS AMENDED IS THE
RESULT OF MANY STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT
THE PROCESS IS A TRANSPARENT
ONE.
AND THAT EXISTING CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ARE PRESERVED.
THERE'D BEEN SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
TO THE PRACTICE OF REAL ESTATE
OVER THE YEARS WHILE MOST OF
THE.
OF THE EXISTING LAW WAS ENACTED
WHEN IT WAS NO INTERNET AND IF A
PERSON WANTS TO LEARN ABOUT OF
PROPERTIES THEY HAVE LITTLE
ALTERNATIVE BUT TO GO TO THE
BROKER'S OFFICE AND LOOK AT A
BOOK OF PROPERTIES. NOW
CONSUMERS CAN GET DETAILED
INFORMATION ON LISTED PROPERTIES
ON THEIR PHONE. NEW TYPES OF
BROKERAGE MODELS HAVE EMERGED
MANY LICENSING MATTERS ARE NOW
HANDLED ELECTRONICALLY THROUGH
E. LICENSING WITH THE BUREAU OF
REAL ESTATE RATHER THAN THROUGH
MAIL OR PAPER FORMS.
AND TRANSACTIONS TAKE PLACE
PRIMARILY THROUGH ELECTRONIC
FORMS.
THIS BILL UPDATES LAW TO
RECOGNIZE THE LICENSING AND
ELECTRONIC SIGNATURES IT
CLARIFIES IN ACCORDANCE WITH
CURRENT LAW AND VARYING
BROKERAGE MODELS THAT A LICENSEE
MAY BE RETAINED BY A BROKER.
AS THE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
AFFILIATED WITH THE BROKER OR AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE PROGRAM ALSO
MAKES TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE
LAW TERMINOLOGY TO MAKE THE.
TERMINOLOGY MORE UNDERSTANDABLE
TO CONSUMERS AND MORE
CONSISTENT.
.
WE CAN COMMIT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
RESOLVE ANY OUTSTANDING.
THANK YOU AVERAGE WAS AROUND FOR
GOOD POLICY FROM AMONG WHO NO
LONGER WILL BE ACTING AS
SUBCOMMITTEE AS A SEER OF CORN
PRESENTS AND SO MASSACRE WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HERE.
GROW UP HERE CURRICULA.
BAKER.
WELL.
YOU.
EGGMAN.
SINCE YOU'RE.
WHAT?
THERE MAYES.
NO ONE.
BY NOT PUTTING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MOVE THE
BILL.
GIVE.
I'M STAND WAY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WHERE THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL. THEY SOMEONE AS NICE A
CARE.
SUMMARIZE WHAT THE BILL DOES
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE BUT IN
IN. IN ESSENCE THIS IS A NUTS
AND BOLTS A TUNE UP ON THE LAW
WE HAVE A COMPANION MEASURE
THAT'S JUST CLEARED JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING THAT THAT
DEALS WITH THE CIVIL CODE SIDE
OF OUR OUR BUSINESS.
IS THAT THE BNP SIDE THIS IS A
SITE THAT DEALS WITH LICENSES
THAT OTHER BILL DEALS WITH THE
TRANSACTIONS THEMSELVES AND SO
VOTE.
WE PROTECT YOUR QUESTION OF WHAT
ARE YOUR AYE VOTE SORRY. YEAH
WELL HAVE A GOOD.
THAT YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW THERE IS A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
ARE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF FOR THE AUTHOR OR
THIS.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ME TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I.
WROTE.
REGULAR.
EAGER.
WHEN.
EGGMAN.
I GRAYSON.
WHEN I.
MAYES.
MULLIN.
STEINORTH.
BUT AS A WOMAN THEIR.
CONGRATULATIONS ARE YOU THINK
YOU VERY MUCH I WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO AND.
CRITICS CONSENSUS AND ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS WITH RESPECT
CONSENT. THING THEM TO RETHINK
THEIR.
AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT TO
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIXTEEN FIFTY
NINE AND.
WELL I BROUGHT.
WE'VE GOT.
YOU.
SINCE I
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MAYES.
ONE.
STEINORTH.
AND THAT IS THAT YOU DON'T
REGISTER THIRTEEN ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUT AND TO OUR
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS TO ALSO WANT
TO WELCOME MISTER MAYES ALSO TO
BMP WELCOME. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR JOINING US I ALSO WANT
TO MAKE MENTION AND THINK OF OUR
PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT LEON JR. OF
FOR HER YEARS OF SERVICE TO THIS
COMMITTEE IN HER LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE SHOULD BE HEADED. AS
THE.
THE NEW POSITION OF DIRECTOR OF
POLICY OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS TO
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES.
AND SO WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
HER LEVEL EXPERTISE AND SERVICE
TO NOT ONLY THIS INSTITUTION BUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE KNOW
THAT WAS CONTINUE TO SEE YOU.
AND A DIFFERENT CAPACITY.
OKAY BIG GROWTH WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN OF FOR ADDITIONAL FIVE
MINUTES FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
I'M AB SEVEN FOUR NINE AYE
MOTIONS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS.
MULLIN.
AT OUR CONSENT COUNTER AB EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT ABA TEN THIRTEEN AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE AYE MOTIONS
DEFENSE APPROPRIATIONS MULLIN
YOU.
NO SECRET PRESS AND TURN IT ON
WE PROGRESS WE CAN.
AB SEVEN FORTY NINE TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS CHILL.
BUT.
ITEMS ON.
I WAS ON CONSENT AB EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT AB TEN THIRTEEN AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY NINE DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS CHILL
YOU DO NOT.
RIGHT TO.
I JUST.
BECAUSE IT.
I THINK I SAID.
WHERE CLEARLY?
READY.
.
AB SOME FORTY NINE.
THE HOUSE APPROPRIATIONS.
I AM GOING INSIDE AYE AB EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT AB TEN THIRTEEN AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE CUNNINGHAM
.
SO GOOD
FIRST THE RESPECT.
HERE WAS SAYING.
THREE LOSSES
AB SEVEN FOUR NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
MOTIONS ON CONSENT AB EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT AB TEN THIRTEEN AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE MOTION IS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LIKE.
IT'S BEEN.
IT'S HERE